this episode is sponsored by google play
with the help of marvel realm of
champions
[Music]
from creator jj abrams comes an iconic
turn-of-the-century tv show
that became a pop culture sensation
featuring
a first season that had viewers
wondering what's in a box
and a time traveling final season that
left most fans disappointed and confused
felicity
oh and also lost wow jj did that twice
how does that even happen prepare for a
zeitgeist defining drama
that started with one simple question
where are we
then ballooned into so many more what is
the black rock what do the numbers
mean what is the monster who are you
people that bridges say my name
what is a nigerian priest doing in an
island in the south pacific
what happens to pregnant women on this
island that even the creators eventually
got tired of answering them
what do you mean get back here what do i
mean
eventually folding in on itself like a
question singularity
as the writers booby-trapped this
tropical hell with literal mystery boxes
and one mystery whose answer is still an
actual question mark
i want some freaking answers us too dude
us too return to the island
a mysterious monster inhabited death
trap that no one will shut up about
welcome to the island everything i did i
did for the island the island killed him
the island isn't done with you yet the
island isn't done with you yet
the island's not done with the yeah
we're all done with this island and meet
these plane crash survivors who probably
shouldn't have flown the same airline
that got hijacked in executive decision
this is oceanic 343 heavy requesting
emergency
landing their son and gin this grifter
too
the millionaire and locks knives
whoa the music star the confessor and
scary man
here on gilligan's eye sorry
where will we get there's jack shepherd
the tortured doctor who ultimately turns
out to be a likable hero
sawyer the tortured con man who
ultimately turns out to be a likable
hero
saeed the tortured former torturer who
ultimately turns out to be a likable
hero
kate the tortured murderer who
ultimately turns out to be a likable
hero
charlie the tortured drug addict who
hang on these are all the same people
even the objectively evil mass murderer
gets a redemption arc
i forgive you thank you john
that does help oh well i guess we still
have nikki and paulo
razzle dazzle they suck
witness a show trying to figure out what
it is in real time
as it veers wildly from a
character-driven drama about plane crash
survivors
if we can't live together we're gonna
die alone
to a gritty showdown between two warring
factions
this is our island to a whole season set
mostly in cages
okay freckles
to a mystery driven by clue field flash
forwards they're referring to you as
the oceanic six to a sci-fi show about
time travel
i'm from the future to an epic final
battle between two immortal brothers who
fight over pulling the
plug out of the island which will
unleash evil somehow while our main
characters all mean in the afterlife so
they can go to
heaven really it's complicated but every
time you're ready to walk away
and swear you'll never watch again the
show will deliver a moment so epic
i love you i love you too we have to go
back
you'll forget they devoted entire
episodes to jack's tattoos
charlie's visions zombie saeed and
hurley trying to start a van
[Applause]
but no matter which era of lost you're
watching get ready for six seasons of
stories that all unfold basically the
same way
where we start with an extreme close-up
of someone's eye
then someone comes running out of the
jungle whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
you're good right there right before it
starts to rain
then someone beats the crap out of ben
you know what i
[Music]
someone tells luck what he can't do
don't tell me what i can't do
don't tell me what i can't do don't tell
me what i can do
okay croise
hey it's gonna it's gonna be all right
it's good
and there's a team meeting where jack
gives a speech every man for himself is
not gonna work
everything's gonna be okay it's gonna be
okay everything's gonna be all right
just have to be patient okay and leads a
group
into the jungle where something happens
that causes them to
run run run keep dammit run
until a mind-blowing episode ending
reveal punctuated by a michael jacquino
music sting
that sounds like every sound ever made
all played
at once
[Music]
lost what i can't be the only guy that
shouted lost every time right
so get lost and revisit one of the shows
that ushered in an era of peak tv
that was doing audience favorite
anti-heroes before breaking bad
genre-driven viral marketing before
heroes and
unpredictable character deaths long
before game of thrones red wedding its
way into your heart
from a creative team that gave us the
geniuses behind 2009 star trek
hbo's watchmen and netflix's daredevil
who are also the same geniuses who
brought us 2019's the rise of skywalker
ridley scott's prometheus and netflix's
the defenders
how can the same people do things so
good and so bad
unless their plan was to intentionally
destroy all the established franchises
from the inside
paving the way for groundbreaking
original television like
[Music]
lost starring
matthew definitely a fox professor x
middle earth who's the fictional band
that's a hit with all the fans
drive shaft you're damn right the snack
from iraq
gambit the campfire diaries the love
boat
dude perfect dude dude dude uh dude
the kid's gone ben solo billy d
williams no new pope yet oh concussions
what's this final destination
you're gonna die johnny you're gonna
have to die john richard said i was
going to die
mr whitmore told me richard albert said
that you were going to die the miracle
of birth
[Applause]
come on damn it push that's it
come on penny push push
push harder
friendly log hello charlie hello james
hello desmond hello saeed hello benjamin
hello jacob
hello echo hello hugo hello jack
hello rose hello richard hello kate i
just
killed the chicken nicknames how long
was it freckles how to score the house
called out to quinn you sure know how to
butter a man up steakhou
sulu over here is packing a suitcase
full of salted fish you want me hot lips
welcome back dr wizard i think it's mr
wizard shut up
pillsbury cool hand deep dish sally
sling shot
barbar kenny rogers what's your problem
jumbotron
shut up red nick man a writer's room in
obvious need of therapy
my mother it was crazy
well i guess we don't always turn out
like our mother's want how come you
never talk about your dad john
nothing worth talking about what your
dad never taught you to use a hammer
no my dad taught me how to drink yep dad
everyone's got a dad is he cool no
dude that guy's a total douche that
douche is my dad
and michael talking about his son
they're not taking my son away
they took my son they took my son they
took my son
took my son because of you i'ma get back
my son
i have to get my son back i'm going
after my son he's my son
my son where's my son i want my son
it's my son
lost no really i'm totally lost can you
explain it again
maybe jyn would have survived if he just
learned to stay off boats
[Applause]
just do it
hey screen junkies is die hard a
christmas movie and are you sick to
death of being asked that question
in a new video we proved it harder than
a harry ellis hangover
watch it now this episode is sponsored
by google play
download marvel realm of champions and
discover more on google play now
noise smart cuckoo cuckoo cuckoo cuckoo
cool
hubba
is that a butter knife my lord have you
come
to butter me